how to sell ads on your radio show so I
got a great question for my YouTube
viewers love you guys our B radio show
who wrote in with a question to say good
video I had the real brother radio show
and I do have video ads that I've run as
commercials on my show I want to know
how to sell more ads this is a great
question and I have a radio show and I
have YouTube channel and I have a
website that had ads before so I know a
lot about selling ads here's the thing
okay here's my two tips
my two best nuggets of advice for you
number one stand for something it has to
be really clear what you stand for and
who you're selling to right so for me if
you look at my channel you look at
anything I do you can tell that I
believe in entrepreneurs so if you are
selling something that relates to
entrepreneurs and you want to connect
with somebody who knows entrepreneurs
I'm the guy to talk to
I'm one of the best people in the world
to talk to if you're gonna sell anything
else I'm not the guy to talk to right
there's only a there's only a handful of
companies if you look at how many
companies there are in the world there's
only a small percentage who care about
entrepreneurs and those guys come to me
because they know that I help
entrepreneurs if you're selling plants
if you're selling makeup if you're
selling statues if you're selling cars
all this other stuff I can't help you
and I'll tell that to people like if you
are not selling to entrepreneurs there's
no point in working together because I'm
not gonna get results for you so it has
to be really clear who you're helping
who is your target market right and if
you're pitching somebody or if you are
even writing to me right you're telling
me about your show what is the real
brother show all about who do you serve
who's your audience right that [ __ ]
moves out of everything that you do make
it super clear so then I can even talk
about you and I can refer somebody to
you if I know you're looking for a
certain market and I run across somebody
I can say hey you got a listen to this
show that's a great show check it out
right make it easy for people to talk
about you so that's number one stand for
something and
two is a little tougher to swallow
number two is make your show better
here's the thing okay I never go out and
sell anything I don't sell any
advertiser on anything and yet I've
worked with the biggest brands in the
industry for my industry I work with
American Express and Google and
Microsoft and Dell and major banks and
major telcos I've worked with all of
these companies but I've never reached
out to get a sale here's the reason why
okay this is really important it's their
job to know what's happening in the
markets that they're selling so if I'm
working with American Express there are
people who are at American Express whose
job it is to know what's happening in
the entrepreneurial market right they
are actively looking for people who are
influencers who are getting an audience
who are building traction that happens
when you build a great show you have to
have people coming away from your show
saying that was the greatest show I ever
heard
that show was for me I can't wait to
listen in next week and tell all my
friends about it right if somebody's
listened to my show I want them to say
that was a great show and anytime I meet
an entrepreneur I'm gonna tell them
about that show right that's what
happens with some of these videos right
you like the videos you comment you
share it it builds traction at this
moment and that's how people find me I
just came back from speaking in Malaysia
I had a keynote speech was about social
media for entrepreneurs I don't know
anybody in Malaysia I have no
connections there I've never been there
how did it happen they found my videos
on YouTube and said wow we need to bring
this guy to our event that's how it
happens because my videos now are good
enough my show is pretty good I'm still
working on it I like it there's still
things to improve on it right so your
show has to be better your show has to
be at the point where people can't wait
to call in can't wait to listen to the
show next week can't wait to tell their
friends about tuning into this thing and
if you get that you get that momentum
going
then the advertisers will come and you
don't have to worry about selling them
on anything because they're pre-sold to
say this is the guy who you have to go
to to reach this certain community your
shows not there yet and that's okay but
here you are you're gonna be investing
your time your energy your resources
your thought process into doing
something that you love hopefully which
is making your show better and making it
have a stronger impact with people
versus going out and doing something
that you don't love which is selling
advertising I've never had you think
about it I'm gonna go on a little bit of
rant about sales now you think about
sales right you're thinking about
following up with people and you're
calling people and following up and
following up and fall I don't do that
okay I don't follow up with anybody
people write to me I'll write back to
them I'll give them a proposal they need
it but I never follow up after that
because the people who you have to
follow up with they're never gonna be
good customers for you think about the
people who keep following up with you
write some goodies trying to get you to
buy a car or insurance or whatever it is
and they follow up and they follow up
and they follow up and they follow up
are you ever happy with that person no
right like the guys there Derek they're
gonna be companies who love what you do
who say this guy is the best of what he
does he's an expert he helps me reach my
audience I need to work with him and
they can be other companies who just
don't quite get what you do and you have
to sell them and convince them and
follow up with them who's gonna be a
better customer and who's gonna take
more of your time talking to right so
instead of wasting your time when the
guys who don't get it who you have to
followup with constantly spend it on the
guys who love what you do and create a
product create a service create a show
that people can fall in love with make
your show better and you'll get a bigger
audience you'll feel more fulfilled and
you
advertised notice to follow belief those
watching like the video thumbs up below
let me know what you think comments
questions down below in the section if
you ask the question of a video response
I really love seeing those comments come
in they really make my morning everyday
when I'm eating my breakfast so please
leave a comment and subscribe to the
channel if you want to see more click on
my face thank you so much and I'll see
you soon